[Music]
show up
[Applause]
chris rock back on stage doing what he
does best and speaking out for the first
time since will smith slapped him at the
oscars oh
richard
oh wow and e.t has all the details
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television
on wednesday night chris performed two
shows in boston to sold out crowds
ticket sales surged following the oscars
altercation and fans jumped at the
chance to see him this is a once a
lifetime experience
yolo i've always thought he was
hilarious i didn't even know he was
going to be in boston until i googled
the incident and got some ads for it
and then i'm dying to know what he has
to say about what happened
with will smith once inside as the
grown-up star walked onto the stage he
was greeted with a standing ovation and
e.t can confirm even after everyone sat
down the crowd stood up again and did a
second standing o showing their support
and that's when chris got emotional
when you see stars like them they seem
like they're on another level and
sometimes we feel a little detached from
good seeing that human
you know reaction and feeling that love
from boston like look we love you and we
appreciated you being here and we're
with you and he felt it and it felt
great the comedian kicked off his set
with a million dollar question
[Applause]
but he clarified if you came for juicy
details you're at the wrong place
[Music]
[Applause]
and i'm still kind of processing
what happened
[Applause]
just hours before the actor's show new
details about the infamous moment
emerged in a letter from the academy it
turns out will was actually asked to
leave the ceremony but the academy
claims he refused
oh wow
wow
multiple violations of the academy's
standards of conduct are cited including
inappropriate physical contact
threatening behavior and compromising
the integrity of the academy the letter
also addresses chris directly quote mr
rock we apologize to you for what you
experienced on our stage and thank you
for your resilience in that moment that
was a
greatest night in the history of
television okay
and by wednesday chris was back on his
comedy a-game his fans full of nothing
but praise
it's funny
you need to be funny it was funny my
eyes were crying
i was loving it everything you talked
about was hilarious he did a set it was
enjoyable i'd say totally lived up to it
i mean he's just the kind of guy that
his aura and um you know whether he's
got you know even if he didn't have
jokes planned which obviously he did
just his energy and being there is so
something i really wanted to see so
that's why i got tickets and i'm so glad
[Music]